hey everybody International master David
proofs here for chess calm and today we
are going to look at a very excellent
and memorable game this is Fisher Knight
orff sozin game on so let's go ahead a
couple moves till we get to the opening
variation putting the bishop on c4
against both ecigs and a6 for black is a
variation which Fisher pioneered and
turned into a very interesting attacking
idea there are other people who played
it okay there's on very famous attacking
player Bella morovich who also played
like this and you know also played great
games I'm not trying to take anything
away from him
most chess ideas actually have you know
more than one parent but Bobby really
did a lot for turning this line into an
exciting weapon against the Sicilian
defense and today we're going to see a
classic game of his and one of the
things that makes this game so classic
is that it sort of established a couple
new ideas which people were able to use
after him so for example I myself have
used the very ideas that we'll see in
this game and so have countless other
chess players so let's have a look at
this game here on so this is standard
position for the Bishop c4 Bishop b3
line against the knight ourf and here
the best move for black is Bishop to e7
I'm pretty sure Bishop to b7 now before
I'd ever seen any Bobby Fischer games I
once had this position in a game and I
played Bishop takes a six here which is
not such a bad move once you get into
this position White has decent
compensation and um I actually won the
game
but not only that not just me but before
Fischer a lot of people you know some
other grandmasters that even play Bishop
takes ecigs here so the idea of sacking
a piece on e6 was known but look at the
move which Fischer came up with in this
position which is much better than
sacking on e6 immediately
rook to e1 is a super super powerful
move by Bobby because Black has trouble
developing if they play Bishop to e7
White is going to play the sacrifice
anyway but now in a position like this
they've got a very very good move
available for their Knight which is to
take the pawn on g7 then come back to f5
and you see for this type of position
the rook is perfectly placed on the
e-file either to break with E 5 at some
point or to play 95 at some point with
your EEP on right so the real Connie 1
is a great tempo if he goes for a bishop
takes a 6 sack later so with the
Brooklyn he won he's getting ready to
sack on e 6 maybe he's also getting
ready to maybe sack on d5 for example
should black play b4 here he might be
able to play Knight d5 pawn takes d5
pawn takes d5 check and now Bishop to e7
Knight to f5 and white would immediately
win back their piece plus they're ahead
upon and they've got a great position or
the black King could take his chances
through the middle of the board which
would be complicated but we'll see stuff
like that in a moment so hold your
horses
so route c1 is a very very powerful move
that Fischer came up with here and the
game continued Knight bd7
Bishop g5 now he's just developing very
very very quickly because he knows what
black is up to what black wants to do is
they want to play Knight c5 to guard the
e6 pawn and permit themselves to then
play Bishop e7 and Castle or perhaps to
just trade off the bishop on b3 is
another way to stop worrying about ecigs
and then play Bishop e7 and castle so
Bobby knows that he's got about one move
to get something going here before black
plays Knight c5 so he's developing
quickly black plays aged six first and
then goes Knight c5 and now Bobby
unleashed a really really powerful move
he played Bishop d5 so keeping the
knight for now right because it was the
bishop that was going to get traded off
now in this position a black took the
bishop and they don't have a lot of
other great options because Fischer's
threat is to play
before attacking the knight that defends
the bishop on b7 so I think maybe the
best thing black could do would play B
for themselves to stop white from
playing b4 but then he can take take and
bring his Knight to d5 and White has a
very good position very very good
so Bishop defy was played and Reuben
Eddy takes the bishop and Bobby takes
back with check so again Bishop e7
allows Knight f5 just winning back to
piece right away right if he blocks with
the bishop and in this position here
White's going to be up upon with a
crushing position so it's really really
not an option for black to give back the
piece you'll almost always in a
competitive game see somebody just run
their King out into the center and
they're going to take their chances with
an exposed King and an extra piece so at
least they have some advantage going
their way in the position but now here
is the key little detail that Bobby had
to have as a follow up to go for this
sac and that is this move b4 which is
just beautiful with the idea of sort of
trapping a knight on c5 and that is one
of the really important things that I
learned from this game and took away
from it was that even though it leaves
the knight on c3 hanging and even though
blacks usually the person playing on the
Queen side in the night or if you have
to stay aware for this possibility of a
knight on c5 sort of losing its retreat
square on d7 so b4 black has to play
Knight a4 so it's not to lose the piece
back and after Bobby trades it and
pushes c4 it's obvious obvious that
white is going to have more than enough
compensation for the piece they've
sacked they're going to regain a second
pawn they're going to have two pawns
against the piece black's development is
bad and their king is in the center and
white has the natural moves c5 at some
point to open up the King so you can
calibrate yourself right now right you
want to know what is enough compensation
for a piece look at this this is more
than enough this is a winning attacking
position for white
black tux the King offers a queen trade
in general when you're trying to
checkmate your opponent's king you don't
want to trade Queens Fischer comes back
black kicks this bishop and goes to
capture it and now what should white do
open lines to the black King okay
don't need to think too hard about this
c5 from white so black takes on d5
trying to get a queen trade on if they
didn't do that but took on g3 then Bobby
would have time to play c6 threatening
the Queen and the bishop right so
obviously his pawn is now better than a
piece so Reuben Eddy took on d5 and now
there is the final combination which is
actually a sweet one if you want to try
and find it yourselves of course I
always encourage you to pause your
videos and try and guess some of these
moves yourself but you can also just
enjoy it
I also encourage you to just enjoy it so
the rook comes teh egg queen a for the
King is caught in a diagonal crossfire
because black didn't quite have the time
to capture the bishop yet he blocks and
Fischer takes it and black resigns if
the Queen takes then white can play rook
to d1 check the King has to move off of
defending the Queen white takes the
Queen and wraps up in a move or two with
checkmate here pretty easily there's
several ways to checkmate in two moves
or if black trying to take this rook
then white could win with rook to e1
check came back here and then night
before check and pick up the Queen so in
this position here black just resigned
they're not able to take the knight
they're not able to move the King off of
this diagonal so they're just going to
lose on the next move a terrific game by
Bobby and I'm going to do a quick
follow-up video where I'm going to show
two games that were played that are
directly derivative from this game here
so they won't
Sara Lee teach you all that much more
but they're really sweet cool games that
look good and they show how chess
players are able to learn a lot from the
people come before them so it really
shows the impact of you know Bobby plays
a game like this and that means like a
hundred people are able to sort of
replicate some of those ideas or use
them in their games or actually I mean a
hundred thousand people once everybody
on YouTube watches this video I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm